zabba play king snore isn't it
no that doesn't sound right King John it
doesn't my everybody this is going to be
my episode for Q a video just careful
for spoilers if you haven't seen it yet
there's been a lot of really good
questions about stuff that I think is
solid season 8 material like a lot of
you have started asking about Howland
Reed he's such an important character in
the books wouldn't it make sense for him
to show up so just because Mira is God
doesn't mean that she has gone forever
but they're just a couple of characters
like you are a Greyjoy who are still
alive but I don't think that we're going
to see till season 8 like they're so
focused on the characters that they
still have on screen right now that
they'll save a lot of the big payoffs
for later so they're just like a lot of
book things that they haven't done yet
that I still think that they'll come
back to in season 8 so I try to keep
most of these questions about the stuff
that's happening this season like what's
going on right now
first question though this is actually a
funny one Bucky asks who the heck is
running the Riverlands Stormlands reach
and Dorne that's actually a really good
question there are a lot of empty
castles in Westeros so there's probably
a token force from each side Manning
those places it's possible that the
Riverlands have been retaken by the
crown with a token force but all the
phrase are dead they were loyal to the
crown so for a time there were just
nobody there but legitimately neither
side really has a big force there so
technically it's not held by anyone the
Stormlands is still held by the crown
are still controlled by the crown
Highgarden was just emptied of all the
Tyrells so because they promised that to
the tarly's there might be a couple of
Tarly cousins in a token force holding
the castle so technically they control
the reach right now and then Dorne is a
big question mark
I think they hope that you forget about
Dorrans are like okay this was a
problematic area for us on the TV show
we're just going to quietly uh sure it
off into oblivion so if there aren't any
distant cousins around there's probably
a military leader that seized power by
now next one Chibs asks if randyll Tarly
is dead now how would that affect Jon
and Sam's relationship because Danny
acted based on Jon Snow's advice well
Jon didn't tell her to kill randyll
Tarly and we don't know that he's dead
even if randyll Tarly winds up dying I
don't think that Samwell
was very close to his father and he
believes so strongly in the cause that
he's fighting right now learning to end
the threat of the White Walkers I think
those concerns override any personal
feelings that he would have about the
situation but you do want to have some
sort of character development for
Samwell some payoff for his family he's
not particularly close to them but
you'll probably have to fill a lot of
those gaps off-screen like you just have
to assume how he might react to that
most of his scenes this year are about
paying off big mythology twists next
question idiots do you think that Arya
will fight in the battle at Eastwatch
because she has the Valyrian dagger now
I do think that she'll fight some White
Walkers at some point but not this
season for the remainder of season seven
I think she's just going to stay at
Winterfell and it's going to be about
her brand and Sansa becoming the
Wolfpack obviously John would be part of
that too but he's not around next
question Belson's turn as destroying and
burning all the food was pretty stupid
she could have used that for her own
armies I think probably the idea that
they wanted to get across is that she
was destroying a lot of their supplies
but not everything it was a little weird
that they went from her complaining
about Cersei taking all the food to her
burning what looked like all the food
but that comment from randyll Tarly
about the head in the tail not being
able to recover it is a reference to
that not being the entire portion of the
lannister in the Crown's army they
probably got enough food to last them to
season eight and Daenerys probably saved
enough food to last them to season eight
so you see what they're doing they don't
want anybody to have too many resources
so per blockbuster television language
just assume that each side now has
enough supplies to last them to the next
season next question Erik asks when will
they show either Jon Snow mounting ragel
or Tyrion mounting Vissarion well I like
I said I think any dragon writing
besides Daenerys will probably push to
season eight like they're just bringing
Jon Snow to the Dragons right now that
trailer shot from next week is so epic
him just standing there taking it all in
drag on giving him the full treatment
it's such a loaded moment because if the
dragon likes him then it's another wink
to his Targaryen heritage how would
Daenerys react to that she would
probably flip a little bit but she's
already starting to like Jon Snow more
and more so I think it'll just be a
really funny awkward moment that
everybody's been
waiting to see for a long time now I
would argue that the moment of John
coming face to face with the Dragons
like literally face to face is just as
important it's in coming face to face
with Daenerys but it seems like that's
all they're doing like they're slowly
revealing Jon Snow's heritage so I do
think that we'll get like a big payoff
somebody else besides Daenerys running a
dragon but they'll probably save that
for season eight next question Josh asks
do you think that bran and bears will
have big secret paths fair seems
different this year
maybe Varys worse for the iron bank and
bran is a wildling so I like the whole
theory that Varys is doing something
secret there's a traitor in Daenerys
myth but I don't think that anything
beyond what you've already seen is going
on Varys has always been so duplicitous
it is kind of weird seeing him be so
genuine this season like there's always
some scheme that he has it's the same
thing with little fingers character you
haven't seen either of them do a lot of
plotting or back dealing but I think
that's only because they've been
focusing so much on the big character
payoffs like bringing Jon Snow to
Daenerys so whereas in previous seasons
you probably would have gotten more bear
as seeing him doing a lot of plotting
behind the scenes you just don't see
that happening on-screen now because
they're rushing things so much but a lot
of you I think have guessed correctly
that when he's talking to Tyrion about
you need to make her listen they're
talking about Cersei so you can think of
that as him doing something shady behind
Daenerys his back like trying to broker
peace with Cersei
even though Daenerys wants her head on a
pike but as for bran being a wild like
no I don't think there's anything secret
going on with bron-bron is bran he's
kind of like the Hound they're very much
what you see is what you get next
question a shawl asks can anyone tell me
exactly what do the White Walkers want
so you have to consider what the night
king purpose was when he was created to
get rid of the first men the first men
had started to cut down their forests
cut down their sacred weirwoods so it's
almost like the night king is going to
wipe the board clean and it will be
nature taking over again he's very
literally a force of nature it's just
the things that he's trying to get rid
of is something that you really care
about all these main characters next
question Garrett as wears Viserion and
regal I hope they didn't die off-screen
so yeah a lot of people were asking why
did she just take drug on I think that
was because of what Jon Snow said he was
all about caution
restraint so I think that's Daenerys
showing restraint okay instead of taking
all three and burning King's Landing to
the ground I'll take one dragon I'll
take my favorite and I'll just burn a
bunch of their supplies I'll prevent
them from getting the thing that they
took from me the grain
next question Alex asks a whole bunch of
question so I'm just going to pick a
couple of these how do you think the
whites will get past the wall and do you
see bran being a sell sword that he is
switching teams to fight for Daenerys so
all into the Brawn one first yeah I
definitely think that you're going to
see some team Cersei people switch sides
what she does really really terrible
things as for the White Walkers there's
so many people that have theories now
because of those opening credits they're
like oh wow the whole northern sea is
frozen does that mean that they really
will just walk around the wall no that
would be blasphemous you don't build a
huge wall say that it's never been
breached and then not breach it so that
is why that episode one comment from
maester eros is my favorite the wall has
stood through it all so while I do think
they'll tease the idea of the army of
the Dead coming around the wall we will
get a genuine moment where they bring
down part of it but I think a lot of
that might be left for the season 8
opener next question Daniel from
facebook asks can we somehow address
where the Tully's is the blackfish still
alive so I think there are a lot of
people that were wondering after last
season but I think the idea is that
blackfish died defending the castle but
edie burea is still alive as far as we
know Aria left him in that dungeon so he
was in the dungeon at the twins we
assumed that he might still be there
maybe someone's led him out maybe his
wife like all the women were spared
maybe the women let him out he does have
a son so technically the tollis haven't
died out the way they make it seem like
the Tyrells have been wiped off the map
but there are a lot of cousins you have
to remember there are a lot of distant
cousins in Westeros that they never
really address like there are a lot of
Lannister cousins that we never meet
next question Callum asks so this is all
about Arya maybe secretly being the wave
I've seen a lot of these theories pop up
so just address this no I don't think
that Arya is secretly the wave and she's
wearing Arya's face there have been a
lot of really good faith stealing
theories pop up I don't think that
they're true my favorite crazy Arya face
stealing theory now is that she'll steal
little fingers face and use it to
control the Lords of the Vale because
that is a funny thought if Arya
where his face what would she do which
he just where his face for forever but I
don't think anything so crazy is going
to be happening Aria is Aria she might
wear some more faces before the series
before season 8 is done but the one that
I'm still holding out hope for you know
small chance it'll happen but it's a
very small chance is that Aria will wear
Jamie's face after he dies and use that
to kill Cersei so you get a combination
of the valonqar being fulfilled and are
you crossing Circe's name off her list
but thank you so much for submitting
questions and without getting too
maudlin I'll say thank you so much for 2
million it's a really big deal I don't
have any special big celebration plan
because I never expected this to happen
so feel free to leave suggestions for
how I should celebrate in the comments
below
congratulations to the latest giveaway
winner bradley hendrix please private
message me on the back end of my channel
so I can get your contact details what
will happen is is I'll post a new bonus
video later this week people have been
asking about the children of the forest
the mysterious markings that keep
popping up it's shown up so many times
during the series but while you wait for
everything you can click here for the
episode 5 trailer video and you can
click here for my episode 4 video thank
you so much for watching everybody stay
awesome I'll see you guys tonight
you